I can't shake like a wrecking ball oh
this is awful this is just awful
[Music]
and this is yeah are you [ __ ] joking
this one this is impossible
is it my turn
Somali so she sang a song
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm yeah oh my god I can't do this
go on I can't do this I cannot do this I
can't I can't do this
what was it it was Tom Cruise why
couldn't you do tell you did some prison
[Laughter]
why'd you keep starting like this I I
feel like I've been tricked American
boys Johnson and yeah yeah it's easier
that way isn't it I found a loophole
this is this is just yeah it's always
better when it's your turn
can somebody tell me why why are women
being allowed to do things I think it's
absolutely disgusting
it's just political believe it is the
traditional role is is impression I'm
doing these are just your opinions
[ __ ] hell
I thought you were a woman why didn't
you go on about veganism Arthur you
[ __ ] [ __ ] hell you've even got
material about ever [ __ ] how my wife
and kids
this is awful this is a career-low yes
that's saying something we just done
with lots of
was that the worst it's ever gone no oh
God
although suggests dropping this I would
stop this is a good guy if that's not
the worst example of this guy being
played you need to cut this this is a
bit of advice
you